top gun maverick is finally here but
what's with those anonymous bad guys and
how did the trailers mislead us about
the movie's plot the best and worst of
maverick straight ahead
there's no doubt about it the thing that
everyone will be talking about after
seeing top gun maverick is just how
thrilling the aerial scenes are i just
want to manage expectations
a huge part of the film obviously takes
place on and over us soil as the class
trains under mavericks tutelage but even
those practice dogfights are a shot of
pure adrenaline as the old dog has
plenty of tricks up his sleeve to get
the best self of the new pilots but when
they start training for the extreme
g-force they'll deal with on their
mission director joseph kozinski really
cranks up the tension maybe it's the
fact that goose dies in the original but
there's definitely the feeling that any
member of the team could be killed at
any second when the team actually
manages to pull it off and they destroy
the uranium plant it feels so satisfying
for the audience because we know how
hard they've worked to get this fire
the film does a pretty good job of
carving out the tense relationship
between maverick and bradley rooster
bradshaw and it's understandable why the
young pilot would be so hostile toward
his father's best friend considering the
circumstances but even so it comes
across like the audience is missing
something eventually maverick confesses
to penny that he pulled rooster's navy
papers to stall his career
why because it made a promise to gusta's
wife that did stop rooster from ending
up like his dad no we don't see meg ryan
reprise her role we're only told that
maverick made her the promise before she
died it's a poor choice of plot
development because it doesn't actually
achieve anything yes rooster's career
was pushed back a few years but he still
winds up becoming an ace pilot and he's
not at a disadvantage alongside the rest
of the squad the reveal about the
promise also doesn't drastically change
its relationship with maverick
since it was already strained in the
first place because of goose's death
top gun maverick is an epic race against
time to blow up a uranium plant one that
requires expert precision and just the
right amount of speed to make it into
and out of the mountains and although it
goes smoothly for the most part one
moment sees rooster nearly get gunned
down and maverick uses his own plane to
save him by throwing himself in the way
it's here the film throws the audience a
curveball by ramping up the tension in a
new way as maverick crash lands behind
enemy lines and even tries to outrun a
gunship that tries to annihilate him as
he runs through the snow
it feels like an extra chunk of the
movie that we didn't pay for because by
that point the movie and the trailers
had loaded the audience into thinking
that all the action had to take place in
the skies it feels very unpredictable in
the best way
no way paramount could have done a top
gun sequel without bringing back val
kilmer as would have been blasphemous
thankfully kilmer reprises his role as
iceman who has since progressed through
the ranks to become a four-star admiral
in the navy and he still bails maverick
out whenever he gets in trouble because
what a friend's for iceman's even there
to offer his friends some guidance with
the team and with rooster when things
start to get tough it's an incredibly
touching moment one that really helps
provide part of the emotional backbone
of the film but as iceman's wife sarah
explains to maverick the amaral is
suffering from cancer and he doesn't
have long left unfortunately he passes
away before the uranium mission and gets
a full military funeral to honor his
legacy it's sad but it also feels a
little morbid considering kilmer's
recent struggle with throat cancer the
star went public with his diagnosis back
in 2017 and underwent chemotherapy as
well as a tracheostomy which has damaged
his voice although thankfully he's been
cancer-free for a few years killing
iceman in top gun maverick and making
such a big deal about his death feels a
little
off
during the finale top gun maverick
delivers yet another punchy air moment
as maverick and rooster are just seconds
away from making it back to the aircraft
carrier following their daring escape
out of enemy territory it's a
pulse-pounding sequence as they dodge
missiles and try to outmaneuver the last
fighter jet that just won't stay off
their tail that's when hangman rolls
onto screen as he swiftly shoots down
their attacker saving the day the moment
works so well largely because of the
rivalry between hangman and rooster
which the former takes too far by making
jabs about goose earlier on in the film
the hot-seated pilot coming in at the
last minute shows he's capable of
redemption as well as proves to the rest
of the squad that he's not as selfish as
he makes out and that he's a team player
where's he going that's why we call him
hangman he'll always hang you out to
drive yes rooster and hangman are the
new maverick and iceman but it works so
well
unfortunately there's one element of the
big mission that doesn't quite work so
well and that is encapsulated by this
question who exactly is the u.s navy
bombing during the briefing early on in
the film it's made clear that the
uranium plan to help the country's
enemies produce nuclear weapons and
that's why it has to be blown to
smithereens but the top gun sequel
avoids actually explaining who it is
they're up against the only thing we
know is that this nation exists in a
snowy mountainous region to the east
somewhere and when the pilots eventually
go head-to-head with the enemy in the
sky they're dressed in black flight
suits with no flags or patches that can
be seen anywhere their enemies even wear
tinted helmets so the audience can't
assume it's one particular nation it's
understandable that paramount doesn't
want to single out any particular
country as the enemy especially when
there are enough political problems in
the world right now but avoiding the
issue entirely almost makes it more
obvious the easy option would be to just
have the enemy as some kind of rogue
terrorist cell then it wouldn't look
like the studio is trying to tipter
around real world situations of course
this could also be attributed to the
fact that paramount wants to make the
sequel universally accessible rather
than alienating a specific market
tom cruise is obviously one of the
biggest a-list actors in the world and
when he makes a movie he makes a movie
top gun maverick is such a full throttle
experience that is easy to overlook his
performance at times due to the sheer
impressive action that's constantly
unfolding on screen push beyond your
limits but cruz's performance is at the
heart of that and it's his work that
really sells the intensity of every
risky move every argument and every dog
fight that the film has to offer but as
entertaining it is to see his face get
pulled back by the g-force cruiser's
best work has done in the movie's
quieter moments
the playful dynamic between maverick and
penny highlights his charisma but they
also have a tender quiet respect for
their vastly different lives then
there's obviously the brilliantly
heartfelt scene with maverick and iceman
which helps the seasoned pilot figure
out a way of making his students
actually behave like a team and although
we have our issues with the movie
killing iceman cruz's performance and
the funeral scene feels genuine and well
earned of course he pulls out his
signature action hero running the finale
but the moment which perfectly captures
what makes cruz great in the sequel is
right at the start when he races
alongside a jet while on his motorbike
the man's got a grin from ear to ear and
it's obvious he's having the time of his
life
admittedly this one isn't such a
terrible crime mainly because it has
been over 35 years since the original
film came out and it's not like it has
been a long-standing franchise with
numerous sequels or spin-offs some
nostalgia is to be expected but it's
almost like a paint by numbers affair at
times
everything you jokingly think of in a
top gun sequel is definitely there it
even kicks off with a montage sequence
of aircraft carrier crew members
prepping fighter jets for takeoff set to
the iconic kenny loggins classic from
the original soundtrack danger zone
there's tense rivalry between pilots
only this time it's rooster and hangman
rather than maverick and iceman and of
course there's the obligatory shirtless
beach scene where they all kick back
with some team building exercises the
2022 movie even recreates maverick and
goose singing great balls of fire on the
piano but with rooster and the rest of
the pilots of penny's bar instead it's
not that these things are bad it's just
that they're a little predictable
thankfully director joseph kaczynski
mostly leans on the right side of
nostalgia here and although it doesn't
look like there will be a top gun 3 any
time soon the baton has clearly been
handed over to rooster hangman and the
rest of their squad
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]